here in Northwest Syria medical staff
have little choice but to use damaged
incubators last week's earthquakes in
southern turkey hit this region hard
medical facilities in this
opposition-controlled Enclave were
already weak due to years of war and the
lack of funds they're now close to
collapse
we have always faced shortages but this
is not new but now many incubators are
damaged as well as other equipment that
we need to treat the children many
children were affected by the powerful
earthquakes where al-rajab was among
those who survived but he's still in
shock
I was asleep when it happened the roof
collapsed my brother and I were trapped
under Rubble for three days before they
brought us to hospital International Aid
agencies say they are facing a
catastrophic situation in the north
where limited access to Aid has
complicated efforts to handle the
aftermath of the disaster it's a
different situation and
government-controlled areas where plane
loads of supplies are being delivered to
airports the World Health Organization
says the impact is significant there but
services are available and people are
able to access them unlike in the
Northwest where it says people have been
through hell
during the first two days in hospital I
didn't receive any treatment there were
no doctors available volunteers or
students were trying to help us
Aid has long been politicized in a
country divided by front lines the
International Community is promising a
scaled up response after the Syrian
government approved the opening of Aid
corridors four million people in the
north relied on Aid before the latest
disaster and the reality is only getting
worse shelter and food are needed on an
unprecedented scale
look at our situation it is cold our
children no longer go to school we lost
our home there are no toilets here
the UN is appealing for emergency
funding it has long been working with a
shortage of funds and what many describe
a forgotten conflict the earthquakes
destroyed already crumbling
infrastructure
we moved to idlib three years ago we
knew the building was not structurally
sound but we had no other choice now
Engineers have told us that we can't
return to our home now we are homeless
the challenge now is to care for the
living who've already endured 12 years
of war zenira